action
someone tell Pat to give me an action
s
Pat could you tell Whitney I did not
appreciate that
your face already did
hey y'all it's us we're her
um uh hold on I just I feel like this
what would our show we're not the view
welcome to the ew
um it's just gonna be us today we're
doing a homegrown episode
um and uh we're gonna talk all things
news all things olds and uh we're gonna
talk about the British Monarchy shit
because I have some stuff to say and I
am I want to burn a London Bridge today
because I have had it and then we're
going to talk about Sydney Sweeney's uh
parents because what's a hotter topic I
know and then what else and the Emmys I
have a couple thoughts t-h-o
T's s okay so I do not want to talk
about the British Monarchy so we're
gonna do it once and this is it so if
you came here if you subscribed for
British Monarchy coverage you are in the
wrong place this is the old uh because
you know I don't have like what are you
what who cares I care I like I I what do
you like about like the British Monarchy
here's like the titles thing is so silly
right and like in America the names that
the Royals use are like insults right
right you know like like those titles
here are reserved for people we despise
like here we've got like Burger King
like we think it's dumb like Americans
had a burger and was like this is arcade
you know that's how not seriously we
take it like maybe it's because I am
American and our whole deal was we left
them for more freedom so we have zero
respect for the terms king and queen
like we reserve that word for people we
truly admire who like earned it like
Howard Stern is the king of all media
right Beyonce is a queen yeah totally
and like like Howard Stern woke up every
morning at three a.m yeah 30 years to
try and make porn stars interesting like
that's that cake that's royal baby okay
yeah DraftKings yep fantasy sports site
to be a draftking you have to know every
player on every team okay and you have
to be committed to a life of divorce
about someone that put the work in Queen
we we only use that word I feel like
besides like Beyonce Queen whatever but
we use that term basically when we're
rooting for your outfit yeah even though
your outfit is not rooting for you oh
like yeah we know what you think you
want to look like like it usually means
like yes Queen like yeah you're so
confident more confidence
in that body yeah we're calling you a
queen because you can't think of another
adjective it's like yes Queen is like
how people in the drag World say like
Rudy Rudy yeah yeah you know it's yes
Queen is like the bless your heart of
the Dragon you know but we don't respect
Royal titles like it's just silly to us
you can buy them yeah it's disrespected
in America like we've got Dairy Queen
yeah Princess Nail yeah we don't we
don't care like the Lord we've got like
landlord yeah we hate that guy yeah Lord
You're the lord of the land
like you're the guy that needs to deal
with the ant problem you know you're not
a lord of the ain't you're not a lord of
the land you're an alcoholic who steals
my mail
Frost royalty is like dumb like we have
like remember Royal Cola royal jelly
it's like Lube yeah the idea of a queen
is just so hilarious to me like you guys
stole that idea from a Beat
and made it your government
you're right like you're like like
that's what this is all based on like on
like bees yeah you know like one
powerful person and the rest just like
go get her stuff like like someone's
like what's up with this whole thing
about the queen and everyone's like you
know about bees you heard about this and
then yeah those things are fucking not
okay yeah let's do this hives are
efficient that's true England is a very
sensitive subject for me because they
have outlawed pit bulls which they
banned pitbulls in England they felt the
need to Bam a mammal just because they
have big Jaws wild teeth and a stocky
frame did y'all also ban mirrors
I love that that's that's like you're
sticking point with England like that's
the worst thing they've ever done
look I don't sorry I don't read the the
Royal Tribune I don't know what else
they've done they used to be called the
British Empire
they were so lame that people were like
we're gonna go get on boats and get
scurvy and go fight a bunch of Native
Americans we would rather risk it all
than this I do agree that the British
Monarchy is as useless as Prince Charles
trying to use a pen did you see over the
weekend he tried to sign something and
he couldn't sign it and there's a whole
montage of him throughout his life not
being able to use pets
13. listen
12 30.
oh God I hate it
everybody's going everywhere
he is the king of England and he can't
use a pen the signatures are important
imagine waking up when you're 75 and
going your first day of work like that
would be a nightmare
wait is that the deal you're kind of
just waiting yes he's been in training
his whole life and he's now been put in
the game yeah can't solve for a bit
can't can't use a pen bottom of the nine
not only can't use a pen was like
actively stressed out by its existence
yeah like had to shoo it away the fact
that there's someone's job is to move
the pen box when he's stressed when he's
freaking out if I'm here my main point
is if you're in England and you're
paying taxes and you're like so
someone's getting paid 100 a year just
to move the pen if he has a conniption
over the
yeah yeah and someone's like got it like
that per that's like the guy that that
gets Steve wins drinks when he puts them
on the table it's Pusher the drink
Pusher this tracks for her country that
raided the world for spices and then has
the most bland food in the entire world
right look
I just gotta I I got it I got a couple
pet peeves I got a couple issues let's
just dig in and the Meghan Markle stuff
is fascinating in the cape middle
because I think there is a lot of
fascinating shit that I've learned so
Megan and Kate Middleton I don't have
judgments about them their life is a
nightmare as far as I'm concerned I
don't envy them they have to wear heels
and pantyhose as I've said before I feel
like Kate Middleton is a stewardess out
of flight that will never land and
but it's first class flight attendant
which is the best game yeah so as
someone who has had to go to a funeral
or two in my day and may or may not have
had to deal with uh my nephew wearing
shorts tivas and chewing gum to my dad's
funeral I must say
when they went and did the looking at
the shrine and the hair down that was a
Miss for me why why is your hair down
okay their hair was like the entire time
like if ever there was a time for shinyo
it's now why is your why is your hair
down it's blowing in your face it's like
in your it's such a sabotagy thing to do
I feel like like both Kate and and Megan
were like putting their hair back it's
like I feel like Prince William was like
Hey can you not rub it in okay I'm bald
at 12. like this isn't even funny you
know how embarrassing it must be for him
to look like the bird that represents
the country he hates most
Prince William was a heartthrob do you
remember yeah I feel like that went real
powder real quick yeah like what
happened like dude someone needs to tell
Prince William that you can take vitamin
D orally there is like a I'm sure they
can get Amazon at the royal family I
just he looks like he's made out of
paper mache like there it doesn't these
people don't look healthy to me no it's
actually incredible like watching some
of the richest people in the world like
clearly having never been to a
dermatologist
why it's your why does why does the
prince look like he's made out of
whatever they made Val Kilmer out of in
the new Top Gun movie
odd to me
have this now there's this older man
thing where okay like women now all look
like lizards like shiny jellyfish
because of lasers but men are starting
to look like Play-Doh like I don't they
have this like powdery finish now like I
don't if you look at a photo of him like
Prince William looks like
what he should look like in an
underwater cave through goggles like he
he looks like he's underwater like it's
not a normal finish you know like it's
not right like he looks like he's made
out of construction paper do you know
those like stucco ceilings in abandoned
schools yeah oh my God it's a tough
texture dude I don't what he's paper
mache he looks like a nutcracker dog why
does he look like the Cowardly Lion
sounds he has a complexion of an
apartment complex in Fort Lauderdale I
wrote a lot of jokes about his skin when
I was on antibiotics so I don't like to
get judgedy about people's appearance uh
unless it's a funeral or wedding it's
the only time because the manners come
into play right you know my rules about
weddings miniskirt or tube top not both
necklace or giant hoop earrings
not both it's not your day the idea is
that you do not draw attention yourself
you make yourself invisible wear camo
for all I fucking care whatever needs to
happen you're the biggest compliment I
can get after a wedding is you were at
the wedding I didn't even see you nailed
it I didn't make it about me okay didn't
even see you so that's a wedding even
there wedding MVP okay you should not be
stealing the show you should be helping
the light shine on the person whose day
it is someone's funeral is not the time
for Bibi so you need to think ahead when
you pick a hairstyle I find it grow I
thought people hair is gross okay it's
gross like you're yeah when girls are
just I mean I do it on the show all the
time I know but girls doing this you're
Scott scratching your scalp yeah at the
Queen's Memorial you're gonna put your
oily fingers on her billion dollar
casket we have to watch you scratch your
head in public like watch your hairs
fall out like they the entire time they
were doing this I just I don't their
hair down was just drawing attention to
how little hair the the guys have for
whatever inbreeding or bad I don't know
what's going on over there they don't
have eyebrows like where are the he like
the older one looks like a poster from
St Jude's Hospital like if you look at a
photo of them like like like okay did
you see them walking in to the uh uh not
the funeral one but before
did you notice anything weird
about them both it was it was Kate
Middleton and the guy Harry and Megan
were holding hands what else what else
what didn't they have
what didn't they have purses tears as
you're onto something what'd you say
tears emotions feelings on their face if
you're gonna go to a memorial for your
mother-in-law or mother grandmother sure
yeah
not a handkerchief in sight not a tissue
none of them had handkerchief no one
thinks that's weird
they knew they wouldn't cry they're not
allowed to show them like that's kind of
part of it yeah they're like you can't
but they've never lost their grandmother
how do you know how you're gonna not one
human moment they were like okay just in
case a tear is to fall down my cheek I'm
sure a hand maybe a Handler had that
this is all part of the bizarreness
someone carries handkerchiefs oh and and
gets the pen yeah I I would not see Kate
Middleton with a tissue would be like ah
England's weak let's bomb them like what
what I think that's what they're afraid
of why would that hurt anyone you know I
just find that very spooky I totally
agree that England did some very
was a meanie
thousands of years ago but like when
people all of a sudden out of nowhere
are like don't care at all about the and
as soon as someone dies like yeah fuck
that bitch it's like if it wasn't your
cause before can you just like wait a
couple days yeah for her body to get
covered in earthworms before you start
like that's the karma like you can just
yeah exactly but you I I don't disagree
with it but it's just funny to me that
like as soon as someone dies we're like
I've never thought about this person but
now that she's dead fuck that bitch it's
just like you know now that she's dead I
feel like we can all agree like when she
was alive would have been the time to do
this right right read the Tweet Queen
Elizabeth II owns the largest clear-cut
diamond in the world it's known as the
great star of Africa
um the 530 carat gem was mined in South
Africa back in 1905
um and it has an estimated worth of 400
million dollars so someone on Twitter
takes this little stat and she decided
to say the diamond is worth 400 million
dollars and South Africa has 60 million
people which would mean we can give
everyone one million dollars and we
would still have 340 million dollars
left
it's a it's not a bad point it's like I
I love the notion behind it she's right
that's right right but like okay so
first of all you can't just like FedEx a
diamond back to Africa you need
Logistics yeah we'll hear that nothing's
worth anything unless someone so true
foreign
that's the whole point
nothing is worth anything nothing's
worth anything until someone buys it
right right so it's so someone would
have to buy it right okay and anyone
that could afford to buy a 400 million
dollar Diamond has already lost all
their money in crypto so no one that
would actually buy this could actually
so someone like Elon Musk or Japan would
have to buy it in a hash and then you
would have to distribute that you can't
just drop a diamond on the roof of
Africa City Hall so I don't disagree
with that but it's just like a fake
solution right you know what I mean I I
I I think I do not think any royalty or
Monarch should be have Diamond like it
is crazy yeah it is you shouldn't have a
Tiffany's in your fucking office right
it's not like she was wearing it it's in
it's in a museum
right she wore it she won she wore it
it's in a crown oh maybe they buried her
with it it's I'm pretty sure it's
sitting on top of her coffin like as
she's like been lying in state the
diamond yes it should be returned of
course but I don't yeah yeah you know we
need a plan Indiana Jones who knows
Harry and Megan yes the younger kid is
Archie oh no sorry they're older kid is
Archie their younger one is a little bit
I don't care oh just let me make fun of
the name Archie I you know what it is
these kids are growing up to be men you
can't even kid Archie like an adult
named Archie is like Archie is like the
guy with the Peter Pan complex who can't
get his shit together the guy who's 45
and still has like red cup ragers like
Archie wears a Blazer over a hoodie oh
yeah Archie is 100 a name for someone
who's a Disney adult okay he's the guy
that we need leaving Applebee's wants to
race to the car
yeah I mean you're like dude he roll
like rolls his clothes when he travels
oh okay saving space Archie's the guy
that like calls people Chief like what
up Chief like chill Archie also it's
just like a little bit she is accusing
them of racism and names her son Archie
it's a little weird you have an Archie
Bunker it's like yeah
um Kate and Megan I guess like the the
thing that I've learned a lot from them
and the main thing I have is I I'm
learning that no one is buying I don't
like that they're trying to be down to
earth yep we don't want you to be down
to earth okay the simple skirt and the
same fucking boat neck dress over and
over yeah the Zara you gotta we get
excited when they wear a Zara dress it's
like we wear Zara dresses we don't want
to see Zara well but it's also the thing
with the the when they wear something
from like Zara or Madewell the thing
that really gets me with that is that
Megan and Kate are then ruining the
people who work at those stores lives
like those people are experiencing in
real time what it's like to live in a
Charles Dickens novel like they they're
cramming so many people inside of those
stores it's like Astro World and they're
not even giving out better help coupons
like they're just they're they're
absolutely terrorizing these poor people
who work at the stores also that people
can get like a 30 dress that they wore
probably against their will for like 45
minutes it's insane that is so funny the
idea that they're like this dress is
from The Gap I'm so down to earth and
then every one of the Gap is like fuck
yeah yeah yeah you know it's amazing man
but it's like we don't want you to be
down to earth right we want you to be
ridiculous okay your job is to entertain
and represent and distract us like your
your mascots to distract us right with
emeralds and hats and and 400 million
dollars that you have your own cobbler
your shoes should not be aerosols like I
want to see some glamor you know at
least like or at least be English and
cool like you can also do yeah why is no
one doing the like English Punk is like
the coolest thing like why aren't they
just like doing that you know like plaid
skirts and white shirts and like I don't
know would it kill you to dress like
Helena bottom Carter they all they look
like um
cardboard cutouts
Stanley yeah that's it yeah you know
those like paper dolls yeah
also like Kate I don't know she's so
thin it's kind of awesome oh it's
uncomfortable she looks like a
protractor yes right royalty is supposed
to be indulgent kittens are supposed to
be fat yep eating turkey legs okay and
they're the one and then you look down
on the peasants that are starving right
you know it's the opposite now the
Royals are anorexic and starving like
hollowed out cheeks and then the people
they rule have an obesity problem like
when did this switch like you're
supposed to have gout you know why do
you look like you have scurvy like why
are you all wasting away and then the
average size of an English person is a
10 like it's just odd I think someone
said to them like you need to downplay
your looks you know like don't look too
sexy don't like
you don't need it no offense but you
don't need to
like also they're not that young like
it's right you know it just
you don't need to dress from White House
Black Market she's like what she goes
yeah like no one's gonna be like oh
nothing's getting done over there
because there's just too beautiful it's
distracting like oh my God I just it's
okay you know I don't know like nowhere
in the royalty manual does it say you
have to be boring as shit no no necklace
there was not even the boat neck with
the fucking I gotta just look at your
necklace not even a Tiffany Bean the
Cartier tank fucking kill you to put on
a Cartier tank just give us something to
talk about yes humans are we run out of
things to talk about okay and we we need
to fucking pass time before we die so we
need gossip it is your job to be our
father for gossip so that we can make
awkward conversations with co-workers
but you're so fucking boring there's
nothing to say except don't look at her
dress I thought Banana Republic was out
of business I shouldn't know anything
about Banana Republic I worked too hard
someone needs to tell Megan she can just
go for it yeah yeah her but this is a
great lesson because she's trying so
hard to be perfect that that's what
makes people repelled yeah they smell it
they feel it like why do you look like a
Norwegian Amish water bucket yeah yeah
like she like I don't people are mad
because I it's not because she's a bitch
I think it's because she's a being
boring because she's trying to not be
flashy and it's just like people love
Diana because she was messy and she took
fashion risks and was narcoleptic or I
don't know what it was but exactly but I
I think that she's trying so hard to not
be messy yeah that it's repellent and
she's
operating in fear and it gives us the
power to judge yeah when someone doesn't
give a fuck people like damn she doesn't
give a fuck yeah it's also like like
it's hard because Megan is like kind of
on a different playing field because she
is from California where like everybody
is a 10 and like are so beautiful all
the time like British people were
obsessed with Princess Diana they loved
her so much and I agree with you it's
because she like wasn't trying so hard
to be perfect all the time she like fell
asleep in church and like she had a ball
rolled her eyes yeah she didn't give a
shit
um but she but but like the thing is
everybody thought that Diana was
beautiful like so beautiful but like
yeah let's be I know let's be real I
know
I'm not I'm a big fan of Lady die
however
she was like an LA sex I'm like like
that that's generous but yeah like
Princess Diana is is Princess Diana
Princess Diana was beautiful in the
British way and that she looks great
like walking through a thick fall right
all three of us are hotter than Princess
Diana was if you look just like like
face basically the average British
person looks like a stop-motion figure
from Wallace and Gromit like was put in
like a like a like an inflatable and
blew up and then like never got their
teeth fixed not you David Beckham
or you Posh but everybody else no one is
um yeah we don't spend enough time
talking about that she wasn't that
pretty
she was
symmetrical no but I think that that is
part of her appeal like she was like
this sort of charming like I don't want
to say but like what the every girl if
she were still alive would we still
think she was a unicorn like she's a
unicorn she would have 40 000 Instagram
followers let's be real
um Princess Diana also Princess Diana
got married to Prince Charles when she
was 19 years old yeah everyone is hot
when they're 19 years old oh man it's
hard you have to actively work to not be
hot when you're 19. yeah your skin is
perfect like you're so thin right eyes
like your boobs are perky like
everything is going well for you at that
time yeah I don't think we talk enough
about the fact that the queen has a
dollhouse
foreign
like she spends most of her private
weekends at the Windsor Castle I mean
she's dead now but before
um I just she she plays with a dollhouse
that's kept there which the Royal
collection trust calls the largest most
beautiful and most famous dolls house in
the world if he has electricity running
water and working elevators wait can
homeless people live in that house like
feels like there are some people that
really use being under this roof I just
think it's weird that you guys pay taxes
to these infantilized adults so they can
play dress up yeah other Hobbies did she
need now this gets us to my point which
is all of this is so appealing to me
because my number one goal in life is to
go back to being a baby I want to be a
baby but and the royal family are adult
toddlers they are dressed they are told
where to go they are fed everyone takes
pictures of them all the time they get
attention everywhere they go they get
gifts everyone's excited when they come
downstairs that is the dream Emily what
what about what is what
girl baby you want to be a girl baby
it's kind of amazing because like
feminist is like a word that's lost its
value but I love that you're just like I
am not a like I am a hardcore
non-feminine like I I want to be called
I want no Independence I don't yeah I
yeah eyes wanted I'm not standing in
your way I
would be feminism all royalty uh also I
think that I think that this is the
other thing that I got obsessed with
this weekend while on antibiotics that
I'm like 90 sure had been expired
um all of royalty stemmed from
sociopaths right right no like who
decided they were going to rule okay all
royalty started as the biggest bullies
on the playground yeah like to be able
to conquer land right back a thousand
before what before Wi-Fi right like uh
before Google if you could just you
would have to just talk like convince
people and like yell across Yonder and I
think you deserve everything you have
because you built a business before the
internet I mean to be able to do that
before mass email and blind CC there was
no like IG lives to be like hey guys I
think um uh I should own Prussia here's
my hear me out like they were going door
to door hot to hot or whatever it was
the first guy that was like Hey I'm King
and everyone was like
yeah and everyone was just like all
right this seems like it's really
important to him let's just like this
like like he's like really seems like
it's a big deal for him so let's just do
it it just feels like a I don't know
what if they were just like guys if we
just like let him pretend for a little
bit he'll shut up about it and then it
went way and then it's just like oh shit
they were like he has weapons
he really oh
screwed up on this stuck the landing on
that you know so the Emmys happen I
don't normally watch the Emmys but I
figured I I don't know people were
texting me like you got a lot like this
is wild it was wild
um
I am in the television world every now
and then and I just want you guys to
know that if you're watching the Emmys
regularly I am so sorry
I don't know why we feel the need to
punish you every year for supporting TV
and also I know these people like we
know these people right the people that
are putting this that are hosting the
show and these are talented people right
they are funny I don't understand why
they're all
being bad on purpose yeah like it's just
I can't
everyone in that room of all people knew
that wasn't funny right yeah there's
something going on that I can't quite
explain to you as someone that is in
this world I agree that those shows are
horrend it's a bunch of talented people
bombing their dicks off right they don't
have to bomb their dicks off I don't
know who I don't know if they're worried
about standards and practices I don't
know if they just didn't allot enough
time yeah I don't know if people weren't
didn't want to touch the pen I don't
know if Prince William or fucking George
whatever
um but that was yeah that was horrendous
I am sorry
um and I also have a lot of gripe with
the Emmys I think they're BS like well
it's Hollywood prom yeah and it's
exactly and it's like you're gonna make
us buy basic cable for one night of the
year to watch all the shows we stream
win an award right yeah yeah yeah yeah I
it is so funny the circle jerk of a
bunch of Hollywood people being like
let's give each other prizes yeah yeah
like we on TV also those prizes are BS
because there was more than one squid
game nominee
what huh squid game they all kill each
other to get to the top obviously the
Emmys aren't real they're more than one
nominee
guys that's a joke
that was a good joke
I just I don't I didn't finish I didn't
watch I couldn't I was like I'm not
gonna read I can't I
watch a show I'm not gonna read
um it is funny uh this girl that stayed
at my house this weekend she goes we
were in like the uh I don't know what
the fuck we're doing and she was like um
reading a book or something and she was
like do you read a lot and I was like
I mean I'm not like against it
[Music]
I feel about feminism
like it's
like it's a me gripe which is like
ER it seems like most of the comedies
are about female comedians right but no
female comedians are ever allowed like
actors get to play actors you know Jamie
Foxx gets away singers gets to play
singers Gaga gets to play you know what
I mean people I just love that people
think
female coming are fascinated by female
comedians hacks and marvelous maisel but
not actual female comedians they're like
you guys are such trash like we can't
let you involve like you're not gonna
ask any of us yeah not like I'm good but
like I don't leave I don't leave the
Adobe but like why not involve why did
it have a female Sarah Silverman or why
don't I have any comedian female comic
right they don't even just have to act
they are you know I don't know well
because they couldn't put them in the
fun outfits because they'd all be in
like sweatshirts and vaping
because it's like the the I feel
attacked the uh that is the truth
because it's like in order for them to
do shows about female comedians that are
glamorous in any way it would have to
take place in the 50s or in Vegas when
the woman's 70. because it's like if
they were to do it about real female
comedians it would just look like
stranger things any comedian with like
any female comedian would see the
outfits that they put on The Marvelous
Mrs maisel just be like no yeah yeah I'm
good actually yeah I guess I don't know
it's just like uh it just seems like
such a it's so embarrassing it's just a
huge misfire it's embarrassing like
there was a there was Selma Blair is
coming out with her pirate stick and um
she uh she's never done TV right it's
also it's also just so true you know
what I'm saying they're just like who do
we get that's injured or handicapped or
like a big it's just like a click bait
Festival so like Selma Blair is coming
out you're like why are you forcing this
handicapped woman to read the award for
best supporting female comedian and a
female comedian show like it's and then
she walks out with whatever she's got a
cane Kane and then everyone stands up
that's so rude if you're like hobbling
down and everyone's like look how easily
we can stand up like it's just such a
blind like I I wanted her to give the
award to best supporting role to her
cane
wait you should write for that means
it's just like no she's too funny it
I don't understand why uh Hollywood does
this and I understand why people hate
Hollywood yeah it's because masturbatory
well yeah this is so self-indulgent and
you guys you of all people know this
isn't funny yeah and you these are the
people that are supposed to be
self-aware for a living right these are
the people that if they wrote an episode
of the office or whatever and it was
about an award show they'd make fun of
these same things yes so I don't
understand how you guys got to a place
where you're so far up your fucking ass
that you can't even see that this thing
you're participating in is not funny and
you make funny shit well In fairness
that I mean is they are so obsessed with
the show hacks that that's those are the
only people they hire
excellent excellent now this this sounds
like it's really stressing you out what
and this whole this topic and as and
because of that I'd like to mention a
word from our sponsor
thank you thank you smart thank you that
can help you feel less stressed okay
help me out okay I want to talk to you
about next Evo next you vote this is
again you guys know I've had insomnia my
whole like stress stuff this is a game
changer this is the only CBD product
that I use because a lot of them are
sketchy yeah a lot of them I I'm like
did you get set of a vending machine I'm
not chasing the Gummy Bears this is like
I was like waiting until a legit one
came around and so I've tried a lot of
them that I felt like were just didn't
even have the placebo effect yeah like
oh yeah I'm like how do you not even
right have that like that's supposed to
be in my head and um next Evo is like it
has helped me sleep so well and I'm so
much less anxious because a lot of times
I can't fall asleep because I'm anxious
that I'm not gonna fall right right
that's a big problem and if you've ever
wondered whether your CBD was working
that means it probably wasn't which is
not a problem with next Evo next Evo
Naturals developed smart sword
technology clinically proven to help
your body absorb CBD four times better
than regular CBD oil because oil just
doesn't mix with your water-based body
they're vegan GMO free gluten-free THC
free capsules and gummies derived from
100 U.S grown hemp most CBD oil which is
found in tinctures gummies and capsules
achieves between two percent and 10
absorption which means more than 90 of
what you think you're getting is
actually wasted stop wondering if CBD is
right for you you silly goose it's a
game changer try it next Evo Naturals
capsules gummies mints and topical
creams which the topical cream actually
really helps with my migraines
clinically proven to be better absorbed
by your body get 25 off your first order
of 40 or more at nextevo.com with promo
code Whitney that's 25 off at
nextdivo.com promo code Whitney that's
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com promo code Whitney
now after I've had a nice relaxing sleep
and I'm feeling less anxious I like to
throw on a fancy new outfitting go out
on the town but I'm sick of buying fast
fashion it makes me feel guilty which is
why I signed up for newly a subscription
clothing rental service for just 88 a
month wild honestly I did not think I
truly did not think that I would ever
want to do a subscription rental service
because I love like keeping stuff but
then I realize I just have too much
stuff like I can't I can't yeah and it's
also so bad for the environment like the
fast like because sometimes I just want
to buy something like a new thing right
for a wedding or a thing you want to
feel special but then you're like why
did I just spend in the big department
stores will put you on a list for
wearing and returning so don't ask how I
know that
newly allows your choice of any six
Styles each month you choose whatever
you want to rent for whatever you have
going on it's totally up to you and the
stuff is so cute that's because newly
has access to thousands of styles from
more than 300 Brands everything from
party dresses to premium Denim and
one-of-a-kind vintage pieces which is
right up Whitney's alley newly stock
sizes in a Range newly stocked Styles in
a range of sizes from petite to Plus
Sizes up to five times plus maternity
they carry labels like for love and
lemons Love Shack fancy Lisa says goth
free people anthropology and more fast
free shipping and returns and
professional cleaning in newly state of
the art laundering facility no laundry
for you to worry about the option to buy
what you love at a discount sometimes up
to 70 off newly has everything you need
to bring your closet up to speed for the
season stock up on a new dress for every
event without breaking the bank say yes
to all current trends Y2K throwback sets
Checker print crochet without feeling
the fast fashion ick get all the fashion
you need while you need it then let Nui
work then let newly worry about where it
gets stored through the spring dream
closet unlocked newly is designed to
give you everything you need to get
inspired get creative and explore your
style check out new trends Silhouettes
and sizes without any commitments which
is the way we like it for your closet of
only more than once impulse purchases
and buyers remorse by renting instead
hey newly do you guys have boyfriends
too
it's flexible I need a date for a
wedding but I do not want any commitment
ideally vintage it's flexible there are
no fees late fees damage fees or fees to
pause or cancel I mean still don't have
your period in this pants but you know
no big deal if you lose a button you a
little cute button spill something or
just need to take a break newly is
already a great value at 88 a month for
any six Styles but right now you can get
ten dollars off your first month of
newly when you sign up with the code
whitney10 just go to
newlyn.com that's newlywed to use and
enter the code whitney10 and sign up to
get 10 off your first month that's newly
n-u-u-l-y.com newly with to use with
code whitney10 newly subscription
clothing rental clothing clothing
change your clothes
okay so real quick it seems like there's
a lot of stress about Sydney Sweeney uh
the girl from Euphoria and White Lotus
is her
if we're living in a world where
if you're famous your parents aren't
allowed to be disgusting pigs I have a
problem
no actor is yielded from healthy
well-adjusted people that make good
choices okay so Sydney Sweeney had a
threw a birthday party for her mom and
there were apparently Maga hats in A
Thin Blue Line people were wearing oh
people over 60 or
conservative what this child this one
comes from a family that thought child
acting was a good thing like they
already know they don't make good
decisions yeah why are yet now you're
mad at them yeah you're like a 16 year
old move to Los Angeles on her own and
this is the sticking pool with that rack
okay don't do you don't get to comfort
actress's Mom okay she did like I could
leave her out of this since when do we
need our actors parents yeah to be good
people like how self-righteous are you
like imagine being like Oh my God I love
this new song on the radio and I really
want to buy it but like can you find out
if the singer's parents have a heart of
gold first like I really want to see Top
Gun but like is Tom Cruise's mom like
sketchy like is she toxic it's like I
just don't know you know like I do who
fucking cares like I can forgive the
Scientology but if his mom right is mean
yeah right right right right right game
over here's the thing I'm anti-sydney
Sweeney not because
I'm anti-sydney Sweeney not because or
trumpers because she's so much hotter
than I am
agree I was like also
strong agree well that's that's why she
posted the pictures without even
thinking about it because she was like
my boobs are in them nobody's even
looking at the background maybe what gay
guy yeah
that's a good point like I didn't even
notice yeah I just was like staring at a
rap yeah I I don't know I just I feel
like uh also though you know I guess if
I were to argue the other side it would
sort of be like what did you think was
gonna happen yeah you know what I'm
saying right like I feel like if you're
that age now it is on you to like
everything you post will be under a
magnifying glass and you have to play
defense yeah also like I'm Sydney
Sweeney's age we've been posting on
Instagram
easy we get it um we've been like we've
had Instagram since we were like right
she should know by now that like you
have to think before you pass yeah yeah
we are jumping to conclusions like maybe
her family was liberal before they saw
euphoria
do you know what I'm saying and now
they're political views and their
daughter's show and now they realize
they're sex traffickers yeah yeah and
now they realize that their politics and
their daughters show are further apart
than her eyes
the fact that Elon Musk has not made an
embryo with her is shocking
I think the funnier thing is just like
why are you posting photos like no one
yeah of your family party but that's
like so wholesome and sweet it's like on
one hand one time I post something with
my family Whitney goes who does this
entertain no one oh my God remember when
you posted a photo of your friends from
high school on a deck I almost had a
heart attack you've been stepping up
your Instagrams lately every time I post
something I think in my head what what
are you gonna yell at me about it for
imagine imagine will you yell in caps it
feels like yelling when it's all capped
no it was yeah you I mean you did uh uh
post this weekend some girl no one's
ever heard of and tagged her and her
profile was pirate but
if I hadn't fucking stuttered man that
would have been like I am so fucking mad
that I just stuck she just tucked it
typo but that was a good Burn yeah it
was good no one's focused on the burn
they're focused on this
when you have a good burn and you
fucking
and then if you tagged a girl then if it
wasn't underlined
the fact that you know how to underline
people that was I was impressed the fact
that your fault I underline you in every
good help the fact that you went to her
profile yeah you would use it by the way
this is my other pet peeve when couples
both post the same thing we're following
both of you no you don't need to vote we
get it you live together you're happy
and you count get one account oh my God
that would be so ridiculous
how is that less ridiculous than you
posting something and then I go to the
next story and it's Houston Post the
same fucking thing
I'm so sorry that I wasted your time
this weekend
I feel really bad about it no I was that
was well used time I feel great about it
okay good I was I didn't enjoy the
seating I feel like this is this she'll
make fun of my shirt now okay I just was
gonna I just feel like it's what Chucky
would wear to bed
you had to get one in since it's like if
Chucky was in jail it would be red if it
was Chucky I thought he had orange oh
okay you're right
um fucked up again I want to talk about
the live show real quick because we did
the most incredible live show I had so
much fun and I just wanted for the
people that missed it I wanted us to
just recap our favorite moments from the
live show we've all did mushrooms we're
all addicted to about shrooms now yeah a
hundred percent yeah I'm like them right
now what was what was where have they
been all my life but I what is your what
do you feel like in terms of how high I
was you were and you were um you were
the highest are you sure no I think you
were the highest you kept eating them
you're not a reliable narrator that is
true I want to go say our favorite
moments from the live show because I'm
curious what yours were okay you're
gonna go first but I do want to say I I
have in the back of my mind you know
when you get like a song stuck in your
head yeah I get like things that Emily
said stuck in my head as like a refrain
and my favorite because I watched it
back there was so much stuff I feel like
I missed because we were all like and uh
I don't know what it was but like we
were talking about something and then
you're like I'm Whitney I'm a collector
of vintage candies
up
like you were doing all these
impressions of me that I didn't even
notice
a lot of voices like oh and then you
were like I'm a collector of vintage
candies
I do collect vintage candies and I it is
sounds so dumb when you say it it's so
dumb
because it is you know vintage candy
sounds gross and old I was like why
would you not like that they're still
making it yeah I just need a different
word than hoarder and collector for now
what was your favorite uh live show my
favorite live show moment was kind of
intertwined with that because my
boyfriend came on for like an hour yeah
big hit a huge one huge hit I was just
reading the comments of how much people
adored Emily's boyfriend the entire time
nobody was talking about us he when he
goes when Chrissy Teigen was here and I
gave her a Cow Tale one of my favorite
vintage games oh is this your favorite
moment one of my favorite moments I
don't think Christine got understood cow
Tales could you just tell us I bet she
did
ah
I bet she got him
probably did I bet she took one bite and
said these days like shit
I bet I bet the mushroom stays better
than that keltic
and then when he was like
candy it was like just perfect yeah like
fucking like arrow in the heart and then
that's what I said I'm a collector
vintage
that's so funny my favorite moment
personally was shorts gate
um which was the moment in which Whitney
made an offhand comment well Emily Emily
said something along the lines of I have
a wedgie or like my jeans are hurting me
and Whitney said yeah you always have a
wedgie
um and Emily was like I'm sorry what do
you mean by that we had to unpack what
that meant and it somehow came to light
that Whitney has uh had a thing against
Emily's shorts for all these years I
haven't had a thing against the shorts
her shorts have had thing against her
undercarriage right sure but no one will
articulate what you mean your boyfriend
articulated it very clear to you he said
uh Emily uh what she's trying to say is
you have a camel toe
camel toe I have a
dick
[Music]
I don't even know what that means
[Laughter]
it's a it's you're okay so you have
these jean shorts that you wear
sometimes that are just they go very
deep into your butt crack in very they
are I thought female circumcision was
illegal in America
so it's just they look cute it just I'm
always like oh that looks a little
painful precarious Yeah well yeah I
think it's because I have my full bottom
underwear takes up a lot of that does
definitely probably partner you're still
wearing full bottom underwear I do not
wear thongs
I would wear long johns but your jean
shorts are deeper into your crevice than
any thongs ever been into any woman's
that's a good point you know you're
wearing a thought that's Den that's a
denim rub and then she showed up the
next day in a different pair of shorts I
bought all new shirts I just love this
moment because it was such a clear
picture into like I just like looked
into your mind and the way that it was
working because every couple minutes you
were just like let's go back to the
shorts what
about my jeans like wait I feel like I'm
very self-aware have you been thinking
things about my jean shorts since the
day we met what about them well I'm just
regular Jeep
you gave me
I love this narrative that everything is
not weird every bad choice you've ever
made it's eye games
you've ever eaten I've ordered for you
every pair of jean shorts it's like
every soda you've ever drank I bought
it's not a narrative if it's the truth
that's not it is
I honestly would lie you sound like
you're singing hello you sound like
Louis Armstrong why are you talking like
that let's leave my head it's a real
real intense moment when you tell
someone something about them oh yeah
that you think they know and you're
delivering them the news for the first
time and that is my biggest pet peeve
not being on the same page as someone is
that everyone knows something you don't
yeah that yes or they all have come to a
consensus about me that I don't know
about because I'm pretty self-aware in
terms of like what's wrong with me
what's unlikable about me what's like
annoying about it I actually
disagree because let me tell you why I
love this I feel like I'm reading the
comments all over again I think you
exaggerate your flaws
I think you're not self-aware on the
opposite I think you're too hard on
yourself well but not when it comes to
my butt crack apparently agree yeah but
nobody can see there but if they were if
my but if it's such a wet if it's so far
up there then why did I get seven an
offer for Seven Grand because they give
you because you're the you're the the
champ you're the MVP they were like this
girl's gonna do it yeah maybe it would
have to be rushed to the hospital maybe
I just have a very tight crack probably
but you but I yeah I do think there is a
link though to your shorts and why you
cry all the time
I think there is a direct she is reverse
seasonal depression she gets really sad
in the summer like she's so happy in the
winter
summer dice I do not wear shorts It's a
general thing I know but because they
are very challenging The Summer's heart
what else can we do it's hell whenever I
wear a dress you say what are you
getting baptized today well you do dress
like the the Morton Salt girl
she's she's cute all of your dresses are
from like a christening and Gilead
that's the thing
that's the style right now Prairie you
can't just wear a maxi pad to work it's
wild wearing a maxi pad right now
that's crazy that's an insane thing
today are you just have like a belt at
the top I feel like you know are you
there God it's me Emily oh my God sumo
wrestler diapers uh I will say one of
the funniest moments for me was when uh
it dawned on you how accidentally
sabotagy it was
for you guys to get Easy Bake Ovens
because one of my biggest pet peeves are
one of just our biggest issues is that
I'm always like hot and they're always
cold and I try to there's so many lights
in here and I am actually made of wax so
I try to keep the AC on and it's always
really hot in here and they decided it'd
be hilarious that for a live show uh to
bring ovens in here uh
it seemed like a great idea at the time
I love that my biggest stress is how hot
it is in this room all the time and
they're like let's get Easy Bake Ovens I
mean to literally
to get their idea was let's get ovens
I'm already baking okay you know what
you're right I might be I might oh I'm
right no here's the thing I am psycho I
I didn't think that was like a
sabotaging thing I
okay here's the thing Whitney can't bake
things actually
it's gonna be hotter I didn't that's not
what I wanted for you
you know what Whitney's face should
never be near
a lot of heat
let's have her just hop for her over an
actual oven on a show she can't put a
filter on imposed or cut around
like maybe I'm an evil manager
don't even know it she was sabotaging
you the whole time at least I can't do
be near me
it was fun it was blast that was Diet
like if that was planned I wish I were
that diabolical you know what I'm saying
like it was accidentally
um that was the most fun I've had in a
long time
so it might have been that's true it
might have been the company huh
I'm a collector on Vintage candies it
does sound so dorky like it's so dark
that's because it is like I didn't
realize I was that lame of a person like
that was ah
yeah why do I have to say that I think
it's like because why else would I have
cow tails like I have all these and
those circus peanuts otherwise you know
what you have to say that I I know why
I'm defensive about it because instead
of being like so hey I'm a pedophile
um check out all this candy I have she's
trying to get Ghost children into her
way I have to be like I'm a vintage
candy I'm a pedophile but only for
Children of the Corn before we wrap up
we're gonna do play Whitney's favorite
game okay so when we're on the road one
of my favorite games to play is naming
fake businesses which is which started
with my actual serious Plan B which is
um I would like to advise company I'm
very good at naming businesses yes and I
remember when I was spending a lot of
time in New York back in the day there
were a lot of immigrant businesses that
like their name like they didn't
understand that it was like didn't
translate perfect right like I used to
go to this um uh uh Chinese restaurant
uh it was called roll the dice Sushi or
roll the dice Chinese and then there was
lucky Sushi I think like two things they
were just like this is just a it didn't
translate it didn't translate perfectly
like there was a car I think called the
Nova that translated in another country
to nogo oh so they know that's so funny
I love I love the idea of like cultural
consultant to let people you know and so
we named stupid businesses on the road
we make up a stupid fake business and
then name it all right you start Grace
what's the first one first one is a
daycare in hell I got uh Rosemary's
Babies I got buns in the oven Hades
babies also I got daycare
okay a brewery on a desert island
Margaritaville
Gilligan's Island
Wilson's
a bookstore for people over 70. Old Pros
home great the Final Chapter
Bibles
also the end
oh God last chapter that was yeah I have
um
epilogue question mark uh uh we got a
nail salon in a prison in a prison okay
I got a Manny pedophile no
or watching paint dry oh that's very
funny I got just the tips
happy nail
[Laughter]
incredible um happy nail what about a
gift shop and a funeral home incarnation
shop till they drop no longer present
presents I
better late than never
a coffee shop inside of a church Hebrews
oh that's so good
um I I think father son in the Holy
roast oh God or stay with me Jesus
Christ I need a coffee
like holy grounds the land of oat milk
and honey oh that's good Let There Be
latte yeah
a florist in an attorney's office
Whoopsie Daisy oh good
arbitration ah mine sucks floor honor
you know there's a flower called Queen
Anne's Lace yeah this already sucks if
you have to explain it Queen Anne's case
if it's a forest at an attorney's office
but that's a shitty one no it works what
about lilligation
so funny
God guys we're good at this wow well on
that note I actually have a zoom with a
lawyer
um
here we go uh at noon but um okay we
love you guys I'm gonna be in
Charlottesville this weekend uh and then
I'm doing uh clubs uh in California in a
bunch of places with new material go to
minicommings.com it's our next live show
Halloween uh no I think it's gonna be
Christmas oh nice yeah we're gonna do a
Christmas live show oh good oh ho ho ho
and then um also uh only fans so we as
of this week are getting on only fans I
will have an only fans profile it is
going to be all instead of dirty photos
and dirty videos it's gonna be dirty
jokes it's gonna be roasts it's gonna be
stuff that I'm not allowed to say
anywhere else it's gonna be stuff that
would get me canceled anywhere else it's
gonna be uh or get me cancer both
um and uh so only fans profile is going
Live this week I'm really actually
excited because at first well only fans
have to be honest I kind of was like oh
is this a it is so much more tame than
Instagram I know yeah I know it's just
like teachers and bikinis whereas you go
on Instagram and it's just like like
girls do like I mean I I like Instagram
is just like pornographic at this point
oh yeah 100 you know so only fans is
actually like really like funny cool
they do people do sketches on them yeah
well um Chelsea Lynn trailer trash
Tammy's whole thing is on only fans yeah
it's amazing yeah Tammy bangs I am like
so excited to do this and uh and being
able to like write jokes and then we're
gonna do four roast specials of four
people and I'm not gonna tell you who
yet
um I might be one of them uh so we're
gonna do roasted windy Cummings roast of
three more people and uh it's gonna come
out probably like really early next year
or like as we make it maybe but um we're
doing the first TV show for only fans
um I'm so like I'm so excited it reminds
me of like when madman was on AMC
everyone's like what's AMC yeah you know
like I love an underdog or I love being
like getting it on the ground totally
it's like when Netflix like when Netflix
want to do a special with me whatever it
was like eight years ago I was like oh
no thank you you guys male DVDs yeah
those homes yeah I'm good and then I did
an HBO one and they're like Netflix
special I was like oh no thank you like
what is this like weird service that's
only in hotel rooms like that's you know
and then I did a comedy Center uh Comedy
Central one again or something like it's
like I should you know I have made the
mistake of not betting on a network a
new platform yeah that have great people
behind them like soon your parents will
know what only fans is but not because
they're watching
like you know yeah but it's also not
it's not it's not it's just it's what I
love is it's also like if you go there
you can't complain about the content
if you put jokes on Twitter honestly
when people look why are they beating up
because you tweeted a joke jokes are not
meant to be read by other people they're
meant to be performed by the comedian in
the dark after the person's had a couple
drinks and uh of course your joke didn't
land right someone read it out of
context at work on a Tuesday in between
two news stories and then you made an
abortion joke of course you know right
so to me the idea of do comedy where the
comedy fans are doing the clubs in the
theaters live and then only fans you're
not gonna go to watch a roast on only
fans and be like this is offensive yeah
you're not gonna go to be pissed off
yeah
you pay for it and you still have that
it's like that's your problem yeah like
you just look like an idiot yeah yeah
yeah so it's like I logged in to go
watch edgy jokes and then I got offended
it's like yeah that's on you yeah
because I do think that that I I get why
people like getting hit sideways by like
a random right you know on a Wednesday
on Twitter like I get that's it yeah and
also the person that reads it they're
performing it in their head yep you know
what I'm saying so it's just I'm the
rose like Comedy Central won't do them
anymore really like no one will do
roasts so I think it's like time so
you're bringing them back for comedy to
be dangerous again
um okay I love you guys and um
[Music]
don't write elephants don't do it
[Music]
Library
[Music]
[Applause]